[Music]
how you doing sir
i'm good man good to see you nice to see
you i want to say
congrats on season two i'm halfway
through can't wait to finish it
uh i'm super happy you guys got picked
up for season three as well
and that's all i got thanks brother
uh i want to ask you a question and
hopefully that you have not been asked
which is i'm obviously a big fan of your
work
i'm curious what other tv series would
you love to guest
right indirect i mean if it's the past i
would i mean
without question it would be sopranos
without question that would have been
the one i would love to have written and
directed on um
and currently now man i um
like i enjoyed queen's gambit a lot
which is only a mini a series but
um i'm thinking what's on this second
that i would be effective on
i mean i like i've just started watching
i have i'm way behind on this so please
forgive me but
i've just started watching the crown um
and i'm really enjoying it
um but i don't know where it's going and
all that stuff so maybe i
maybe i would throw my my hat in the
ring on that one uh black
black mirror right black mirror would be
a good one actually i could see you
being very good at that
yeah uh i know i normally don't ask
personal questions however your daughter
helmed an episode
of of season two so i really want to
know
first she did a great job but what is it
like in the
like the screening room when you're
giving notes because normally
you know it's a it's a director but this
time it's your daughter
what is that like for you well she was
she's been around so much and watches me
with the other directors so she sees
how i how i work with each of the
directors as they come in
and how what what latitude i'm you know
how much i
support them and say i don't want you to
copy me i don't want you to do something
safe i
you know for me this is not a journeyman
thing where you come in and
you just a widget inside of our system
you need to come and make sure that this
episode no one but you could have
directed it
she watches me do that and then she
watches me give them advice when we're
watching dailies together in the room
with the crew
pre-covered we would all sit together
and i'd say hey
i'm not sure that that seems paced right
i think you should try that again and
get this and go reshoot that
so i did exactly the same thing with her
and um
and and i think she appreciated it it
actually went incredibly smoothly
i was worried it might be a little
fraught emotionally fraught but it
wasn't
it wasn't at all it went very smoothly
and i cast
the directors for the episodes as as
best i can where i think that their
liens would be
uh uh celebrated you told me in the past
that you know where the series is
ultimately gonna end
and i believe you've talked about how
you're aiming for 40 episodes while
making season two
how did did that change at all um can
you sort of talk about how
ultimately you guys do know where you're
going
yeah you know when we started season two
it became really evident very clear that
we needed to figure out
a lot because i am not of the mind to
start telling a meandering story and
then it goes this way in that way and it
doesn't really
uh fulfill itself at the end that those
things didn't mean anything and you
could you know
and i i assume in long form you have a
certain tolerance for
it's finding itself but i found that i
was intolerant i needed to know that
everything was building towards
something so we
had this you know burden on all of us to
figure out the story and when the
pandemic hit
um and we all hiatused we took the time
to
uh you know just figure it out i just
wrote out every idea i could on the
board of where from that
place that i wanted to go backwards and
wrote as much as i could out and
and it kind of laid out in a very
interesting and compartmentalized way
over
40 episodes you know so that two more
seasons after this season
and we started writing you know the
third season and then we got greenlit
so we're we're hopefully you'll feel
that when you watch it that there's this
you know hands that are holding you that
know where they're going
i know that you guys got shut down for
kova during the making of season two
yeah um how did that because i think you
did six episodes before you got shut
down right
how did that impact the scripts of the
last four
it was a great opportunity to
double check everything and reevaluate
everything like you saw
where are you where how many have you
seen i've seen the first five of season
two
okay so we if you look at episode seven
you'll see the first of the
pandemic post you know in the pandemic
shot
episodes and you can you'll see we had a
chance to
really fine-tune everything and again
know where we were going in season three
at least aspirationally
uh so we were leading we were we could
put those seeds in so it was
it was very you know healthy for us to
have extra time you know extra time is
is is good for writing so we we took
advantage of it
yeah a lot of the filmmakers i've spoken
to recently talk about how the pandemic
actually
will improve so many scripts in
hollywood because everyone had more time
yeah yeah this whole jamming one of the
negatives of long-form storytelling
is the amount of material that's needed
and the amount of time
uh that's required is is is so little uh
compared to that the amount of time
that's given is so little
as compared to a feature film where
theoretically you have
much more time i'm only doing two hours
of material and i'm spending two years
to do it
and and uh tv shows that are even in our
episodes for 10 of them that's
you know 10 hours so it's in one the
same in one year that's
that's a big difference in the amount of
time you have so it's needed
i know you wrapped on old which is your
next movie
and i know you've i think you told me
last year that you had ideas for your
movie after that and the movie after
that um is that still the case
it is i i it is the case it's been
strangely
um clear the things that i want to make
and that i'm
i'm i'm striving for i'm already started
writing the next movie
um hopefully over this break because
everyone will be off for the next two
weeks
i'll be able to uh start writing more
be writing that more i have to figure
out when i'm gonna shoot it that's still
up in the air a little bit but i do
in my head i have in my head what i
would like the next
few movies to be i know i gotta go but
do you have a title for the next movie
not confirmed yet not confirmed i wrote
it i wrote a title in the notebook
that i thought i'm taking the notes in
but um
it's not confirmed yet but i can't wait
to talk to you about it i can't
we'll be talking about it's very soon
very soon
can't wait um hey listen congrats on
everything and good luck with the rest
of your interviews today
thanks steve